um
so as as as that's uh
you know that's um happening let me just
introduce the families so okay leo eldar
of course
you know he's he's a co-author on this
paper so uh
and um
and he um he's in in israel now he works
works for the government there so
um and then daniel upon is um
is uh is from nist
he's he's been working on
um on this um on the nist challenge uh
you know in terms of picking a good uh
post quantum crypto system so you know
it's
looking forward to
seeing what you have to say about um
about all this and and why the topics
are of course
and then uh we know it because
uh is on the faculty at mit he's um he
works in cryptography and i think he's
done a lot of the you know fundamental
work on
using lattices for in the in the context
of cryptography
and then i think there are a lot of
experts on the in the audience so um
you know chris picard uh zuika brakawski
shafi goldbazzer so i'm i'm hoping the
various others so i'm hoping you will
you'll
jump in as necessary and
you know so
be an extended panels um
okay
so
uh let's see we'll wait for leo and sean
to
to
put sean's videos to be i'm back here i
don't know
yeah somebody's somebody spinning the
uh
and leor uh let's see
has he not joined
i don't know
uh maybe he has not uh if
sean do you want to email him but we can
get started in the meantime yeah
okay so
so maybe uh
uh shelby
you know if if uh if he can take
just a few minutes each you know
daniel and win out in in
order to your reactions to the token
daniel you want to start
sure yeah so um you know uh it it seems
like a fantastic result um you know
you know it seems you know like a very
interesting you know breakthrough and uh
and it's raised a lot of you know very
you know important open questions like
somebody had on your final slide of well
you know you have this kind of new
perspective new approach and
um you know
uh where can it be applied exactly um
you know so so one of the you know most
important things from you know from this
perspective will be you know does this
impact you know the current ongoing
process um you know does it you know
attack the candidates that we have which
are you know i you know in a different
parameter regime of course right um
and uh
and whether you know that's the case or
not i mean so my initial impression is
the result is both correct and doesn't
as is
you know reduced bit security of of
things um you know because you're
getting a sub-exponential approximation
factor in quantum polynomial time but uh
you know you're not as yet finding like
you know key recovery you know on on
some of these schemes which are you know
extremely short um
but there is this important question now
of of where does this go
um you know what what you know
what avenues of attack are opened up by
this result right
um and so
uh you know that's that's my initial
thoughts it's you know it's extremely
you know fantastic work
thanks daniels
[Music]
um so uh so great talk um sunshine um
uh so i think in my mind the um
uh the sort of important question is
what happens when the rank of the
lattice becomes large the k parameter
becomes large let's say
you know um even super constant is great
but uh but all the way up to like square
root n which i think is where the
problem becomes so you know the
dimensional reductions stops kind of a
you know there's an information
theoretic limit right
um so uh so i think you know um so let's
say when the rank is root n
um and all the other parameters remain
the same i
don't see a classical algorithm um that
solves the problem and i think
anything there would would actually be a
um you know would be so i think the
experts here
uh maybe some of us can jump in but uh
we don't believe that it's classically
solvable right now
um so so i'm curious to see sort of the
sort of the uh the sort of the
adaptation of this result to sort of
larger k larger rank
um if i can
sort of say just uh can you hear me
are you okay
uh leo yeah
yeah can you okay we should move him
onto the screen if we can yeah
okay
so
if i may just uh
comment on that
um
i think like the quantity of interest
that we have come to observe the
important one is actually
kayla q
um
so k-lo-q we can tolerate something
which is like
linear in n maybe n log n
so if you want like to bring up k
uh to be
like
i don't know square root n then uh q
should be say two to the square root of
n
and then which i would say
you need to calibrate your alpha to be
something which is interesting say
2 to the minus n to the fourth a what's
it is minus square root of n because
then we just avoid the problem
so there's like there's like there's a
four dimensional space here parameters
like you have the dimension input
dimension the other dimension the rank
the approximation factor
um but in terms of the quantum algorithm
you need to somehow upper bound
the rank times
log of the of the ring order
uh to be like linear in in
this is like the most general statement
that we will probably have in the favor
i see
so i guess
perhaps chris has a question he has his
hands up um
yeah hi um thanks
so i
just been thinking about the things that
have been
said so far on the comments and
questions
and i think it's plausible that there
might be a classical way of implementing
the worst case to average case step of
the uh proof or the step of the
algorithm that sean talked about in his
talk
and uh it's using essentially
like kind of the
the standard or well-known lwe to lwe
self-reduction or bdd to lwe
self-reduction
and uh so the the high level idea is if
i understand right the input instance uh
this worst case instance
we have a kind of a lower bound on
lambda one we're promised a lower bound
on lambda one if i understand correctly
and that means the smoothing parameter
of the dual lattice is is upper bounded
uh by essentially the inverse of that
with a root n factor but the signal
polynomials
so
i think you can
i think it's plausible that you can
prove that if you take a
gaussian integer combination so gaussian
distributed integer combination
of the rows of the input instance
that you will then get uh you know
legitimate lwe samples out uh uh in the
in that for the average case instance so
you'll you'll get you know random uh a's
and then you'll get h's that are
like s times a with some gaussian noise
and so
yeah
uh so
uh so are you assuming that the input
lattice has a lower bound on lambda 1 as
a function of q
so i i didn't catch that
yeah so as i understand it the input the
input lattice the worst case lattice you
in order for it to be a valid bdd
instance you need uh guarant a lower
bound on lambda one of uh of the input
lattice correct
yeah so i guess um well i mean alpha
times lambda one should be larger than
something that would allow you like
brute force enumeration
for start you know
uh
but like essentially it's not there's no
like bound in terms of q
like it can be much like i don't know as
far as i can tell right now could be
like exponentially smaller than q
um
[Music]
i was gonna say just like two to the
square root and
you know to some power i think right
sure
so
uh so as long as you have a lower bound
on lambda one
uh for the input lattice
um you can get immediate you immediately
get a bound an upper bound on the
smoothing parameter of
the dual lattice
and uh
taking a integer gaussian combination of
the rows basically corresponds to
uh taking a a gaussian modulo the
the dual lattice the smooth dual lattice
so i'm not like i'd have to write down
the
calculations which are not terribly hard
pretty standard but
the idea being if you wanted some
provable statement about
random gaussian
combinations of
the input rows
you could get such a statement
and you could
prove that the resulting samples you
produce are real like properly
distributed lwe samples
and that would even go for any choice of
k essentially so whatever if k is 1 2 10
whatever
it would hold all you need is the lower
bound on
minimum distance in the original lattice
so
that is to say
one should try to
see whether this works classically
and i think leo and damian had some
comments earlier about in the chat about
whether
what the complexity of that
resulting problem would be
i
we we should check that too but
that's a candidate idea for
implementing the worst-case average case
part classically
uh i i think that maybe it would be a
good idea if we took this offline but
actually i think sean and i tried right
john this is like from the north lecture
notes
uh we worked pretty hard on those uh so
i think we came up with a similar
argument
uh for some reason maybe we we read them
wrong but like there seemed to be
uh like a lower bound on q uh it needed
to be like at least two to the end
for the argument that you're sketching
first uh to work
uh no there's
well there's no there's no explicit
lower bound on q needed for this to work
you just need a smoothing parameter
upper bound
yes somehow it came out of the fact that
you cannot sample from the discrete
gaussian on the dual lattice unless
you're
uh you know exponentially larger than
um
uh
like then
somehow i remember exactly the argument
it somehow depends on the fact that you
cannot
[Music]
um like if you're given a lattice l star
like dual of something uh you cannot
assume that you have a basis which you
know the vector's length
yeah we don't need that
but you don't need to example from the
from the dual lattice you only need to
sort of you know sample uh
this sort of a mental experiment right
uh you sample a vector reduce it modulo
the parallel pipette of the dual lattice
you just want it to be random and that's
that all you need to do is
so so i think um you know it would be it
would be great if you put some around
you know so this was a great discussion
but maybe to let everybody else into the
in on the secret could you could you
summarize or one of you summarize what
what uh
what's been suggested and what
yeah so um
uh so i can try um uh so the the sort of
the key step um
here seems to be a sort of worst case to
average case uh
reduction you take a bunch of sort of uh
bdd samples which are worst case lwe
samples and produce sort of lwe samples
so average case cell degrees
um so one way to do this would be
sort of some form of you know you take
the lwe samples um
take some random subset of these things
with appropriately chosen random
coefficients and sum them together so
that would certainly produce samples
that look like lwe right so the lwe
samples are a and a dot s plus e right
here many of these things you pick
random subsets of these things so you
will get an a a prime and a prime dot s
plus e prime of the right form uh the
question is really the distributions of
a prime and potentially also a prime
so the whole discussion here is saying
that you know uh uh one can make sure
that the distribution of a prime is
actually so you need two things right so
one uh
the linear combination that you pick
should have enough entropy uh to make
sure that a prime is random and two it
cannot have too large a coefficient so
you know the error uh stays small
these are two opposing constraints and
um
and we have a pretty good understanding
of how to you know uh uh balance the two
uh and sort of the answer is uh the
smoothing lemma of uh
machancho and regev they tell you
exactly what the trade-offs are so the
trade-offs turn out to be you know um
you know if you sample uh a vector whose
entries are gaussian just like chris
said
um
um uh you you you
that's the coefficients you use to
compute the linear combination right
um the question is how large the
standard deviations how large how wide
the gaussians have to be
they have to be wider than the
nth minimum of the dual lattice so
that's the technical because once that's
the case you know this randomization
works great
so now the question is what is that
number the nth minimum lattice and that
is roughly inversely related to uh the
first minimum or the minimum distance of
the primal lattice right
so so for bdd to be again you know there
are lots of parameters here for bdd to
be sort of well defined
the minimum distance of the primal
lattice has to be somewhat large or
rather the bdd instance has to be
very close relative to that number so
that that'll be that that number is
large and that means that the inverse of
this number which is the nth minimum of
the dual lattice
is small and that means that i can pick
a small gaussian and compute this sort
of linear combination of things
it seems like things are all things all
sort of compile um
um you know and and i think the final
comment of uh that chris had is that uh
you know this process happens uh in
other directives uh you know uh the
quantum production of qe so that that
has two parts one of them is a purely
classical part
which takes bdd and reduces it to lwe so
it's a purely classical part the other
part is a quantum part that takes s ibp
sort of shortest independent vectors
problem and reduces it to bdd that's the
quantum part but we don't really let's
not talk about that right
um
so so that's sort of you know the all
the everything that we are saying here
is contained within that uh that uh that
theorem
um
so that's okay so to sum up again um so
there is a worst case to average case
reduction sort of classically for bdd um
and um
you know um
um
and and and um
um
you know if there's quantum magic i i
would expect that to happen on the lwe
land somehow right so once you do this
worst-case traverse case reduction
you use somehow you know uh
uh
um
yeah
so so maybe just if i can add that sort
of the standard if you want to apply the
standard workspace to average case
reductions right even though this
lattice comes from like it has one
generator it's an n-dimensional lattice
so if you just like just you know follow
what's written in in regis paper then
you you're just going to get like
an n-dimensional lwe instance which is
not what you get so what you want is
like a worst case the average case
reduction that sort of preserves the
fact that you started from uh a qr
lattice with a single with a single
generator this is why search is saying
oh i can just you don't just plug in the
the known uh or the regivs worst case
the average case
is that right i mean yeah you have to do
it like in an lwe to lwe way but that is
compatible with like syntactically with
the problems that we have at hand here
yeah yeah yeah just just to say yeah
yeah but that's an important point to
clarify
maybe just to
note if i can build on your questions a
little technical but
so when you do the classical reduction
say you know you have this
these lecture notes lecture four where
you start with q from worst case bdd to
average case bdd you start so the queues
are different here so there you pick an
arbitrary queue
um so that you can sample from the dual
and that's so you start with an
exponential q
now but that's for a worst case ladder
yes here we're starting with a q area
lattice and then the question is can you
sample you know what what can you do
uh what parameters you get if you start
with the qr lattice to begin with when
you try and sample from the dual and
then come back and generate the lwe
instance
right that's that's what we mean by
there's a lwe to lwe self-reduction
so
it starts being q airy like lwe is and
it gives you more
lwe samples right the same queue and all
that but we're but we're not starting
with lwe right we're starting right but
so the it's a worst case lwe yeah yeah
that that's where all the that that
matters right that's the key point right
yeah but by you my point is that um
it's worst case but you have you do have
some lower bound on the minimum distance
of the input lattice and that's all you
really need to make
the
to prove
that the output samples lwe samples you
get are
like properly distributed that the a's
are uniform and so forth so you don't
need
the input instance to be truly you know
uniformly random lwb just need a lower
bound on minimum distance which is
precisely the
i think the guarantee the promise that
your
problem has to start with
okay i don't know what conclusion you're
drawing from that though i guess right
here
my conclusion i think up to like up to
writing down the parameters i think
you can
run the lwe to lwe reduction
on
the input instances that you're
considering
and be able to prove that you get
properly distributed lwe samples out
which is what you're which is so i'm
saying you could plausibly replace
the quantum
reduction with this classical one
okay but once the parameters are checked
you have some parameters in mind i mean
the sketch is certainly there but you
have actual you know do you know how to
pick the parameters or do you get the
same k for example or do you just you
get the same k yes okay so you get the
same k and then
the um the i would have to write it down
but the
the gaussian
standard deviation you would use
would be essentially the inverse of the
minimum distance
of the input lattice
um ignoring small poly factors yeah so
like one over two square root on the
same
yeah and then um
the amount of noise
it sort of the noise would then grow by
a factor of that uh
that standard deviation
so if the noise started as 2 to the
minus 2 root n then it would become
2 to the minus root n or something like
this
can i ask though so i'm sorry i'm kind
of
insistent on this question so if when
you fix the variance of your discrete
gaussian and you want to be above the
smoothing parameter of the dual
um
so so somehow
you need to be like well above this
moving parameter for you to be able to
uh actually sample from the sweet
gaussian right no no no so again you're
not sam you're not sampling from the
discrete gaussian over the dual lattice
it's very important you're sampling from
the integer lattice the ordinary integer
lattice
and reducing modulo the uh
the that dual lattice so it's easy to do
the sampling for any parameter you that
would be relevant here
oh actually you're not using like gp08
no no
no okay
so it sounds like this is all
worth checking out right it's um it's
always writing down and seeing
um
[Music]
uh
let me let me just uh by you know so if
i i don't i don't know if there's more
to say about that you know i mean this
is this sounds like it's it's uh
it's a useful thing to to understand
well what's been solved and
what the what the classical analog is um
let me just ask um
uh
so
so
let's say that you know let's say that
the same or similar parameters or were
possible classically or
you know this yeah so uh
it's um it's slightly
you know
it's it's either the same or
like it was in in
in the in the lwa case with uh with
other dragons reduction so
grace you had
you had corresponding classical
reductions which
didn't quite achieve the same bounds but
came close in some some ways so let's
say let's say that it was one of these
two situations but
even if it even if it was
is this an interest are these
interesting
questions that
uh you know to look at classically or is
this
is it are these questions that have been
looked at or what where where do we
stand on that
so you know
is is this style of of of parameter
range is this is this an interesting
parameter range for you to look at
yeah i think so i think i think yeah i
think i think very much so um
so so so let's so so this is just a sort
of uh reiterate
uh lwe either worst case or average case
uh mod q which is two to the n
and uh the sort of the bdd ratios one
and two to the row ten and let's say the
rank is uh is also uh root time let's
say
leo here
i
um
to circle back on on the cryptanalytic
impact so our impression with damier is
in in the case k equal wanna
and
in the in the average case not in the
random case this result is already known
this is already
the established
complexity for for those parameters
uh
i but it was it was not exactly clear
what happens for for larger k
um i i think uh in the light of uh
the comments that have been made
uh about the the potential application
of these results it would be nice to
have a clear
and full statement about what is exactly
the claim for full archer k to see if it
is actually better
than what is known in the average case
classically
great yeah
um
i i wonder you know we should probably
be wrapping up in a in a little bit but
um
if um
you know since daniel is here on the
panel i just wanted to i didn't i just
wanted to ask in terms of the nist
challenge and uh you know
can you say a little bit about where
things stand there and also
um in terms of stress tests of the
crypto systems that you look at
you know well this is one one direction
in terms of quantum algorithms and
designing them for a fundamental task
but
what are the stress tests you look at
and well you know where does all this
fit in into the continuum
right so um you know the first comment
here is that you know this is this is
still you know largely community driven
so you know when people you know have
new results and they come and they you
know present them in papers or they you
know have discussions on the forum um
you know that's where a lot of it comes
from um in terms of the you know current
understanding of say like the bkz
algorithm i think we you know it's it's
it's relatively
you know kind of settled down i mean i
think we have a much better
understanding of of the exact you know
concrete complexity um you know if
you're just kind of like you know gonna
do a head-on attack you know trying to
do a key recovery given a public key uh
for say somebody's lattice systems um
you know there's there's you know i
guess there's still you know
people are still digging into like the
little details and they're saying you
know you end up with oh the you know the
my block size is supposed to be one
higher or lower or something you know in
the various estimates for the for the
concrete security but for the most part
it's it's you know pretty well
understood now um you know some of the
you know
the big questions are
um particularly in the case of uh
these new quantum algorithms um i mean
so there's been some discussion of uh
whether for instance the structured
lattices um have a have a better um you
know quantum algorithm that you know
that can be demonstrated and you know it
should be fearful of certain structures
you know and things like ring lwe or
module lw and so on um this this you
know in this situation here um you know
on some level it it seems to have you
know this this attack is you know sort
of showing that you know maybe even the
quote-unquote unstructured lattices
still have you know just just a little
bit of structure that can be taken
advantage of by these quantum algorithms
um you know the
the
none of the quantum algorithms that
we've seen yet um you know then there
has been you know i would say you know
noticeably new ones
uh you know coming out here in the past
you know six months a year everyone's
been sitting at home has plenty of time
to do research and so you know um so
we've been seeing some new ideas um
the
right now as far as i can tell it
doesn't impact you know concrete
security of like you know things you're
gonna put in software and deploy um you
know the but the question is when you
see new techniques it's always you know
even if you can say oh well you know if
i could
somehow stick this into some kind of
actual attack and you know reduce the
security of my scheme by a bit or less
than a bit of security if the if the
scheme or sorry if the technique the
attack technique is fundamentally new
has a new perspective um you know we're
not in the i would say same exact
position
um in terms of you know we know we
understand bkz and we understand that
you know if you're doing sieving for
instance and you're using these locally
sensitive hashes and so on we have a
pretty good idea that you know you can't
really improve you have to do something
different so this is something different
um and so you know i think one of the
most important questions
especially given that we are nearing the
end of the third round and at some point
have to like you know you know
you know make a decision here like we
kind of our own timeline here um
some of the questions here will be
um is there an angle um you know in
which you know this technique that we've
seen today or other ones that are you
know these these new quantum tricks if
it seems like there's a path forward or
if it's like oh well you know we've
gotten to a sub exponential
approximation factor but you know we're
not going to suddenly see you know you
know very very very small approximation
factors in the future or maybe we will
and i think that's something for for
people to consider and consider you know
of course it's an interesting question
saying can i take the quantum algorithm
written for classical one um you know
but whether you're classical or quantum
you know if the new technique lets you
get you know significantly better
because it's simply new
so that's that's kind of like a
philosophical question to be honest yeah
and you mentioned the timeline can you
so what's the current timeline i've lost
track of it so um so
uh the current timeline i believe um
dustin moody who's the project lead um
has posted on the pqc forum um a bit ago
to uh i think send in you know any kind
of final results any kind of final crypt
analyses or you know etc uh new data and
so on um i forget the exact
uh date off the top of my head it's on
the forum if you just look for dustin
moody's post um and so you know the
timeline has been that we're going to
you know set a date where we say send us
all your information that you can and
then we'll kind of you know do an
internal review that will take
some number of months so approximately i
would say the plan has been uh to you
know pick initial standards
um uh around december maybe early
january of this year so in you know so
within a couple months actually is
improving with a point and and then what
happens after that what's the timeline
after that uh still to be completely
announced um there's been discussion of
a fourth round with further candidates
as well as discussion of potentially
introducing an on-ramp uh for signature
schemes in particular
um and uh so i think you know i don't
want to speak on behalf of you know
what's going to happen in the future and
what the entire team is going to decide
right but um that those are kind of the
ideas that are going around and so you
know i think i think we want to you know
make good decisions initially so that
these things get deployed
and you know and and
at some point consider you know if we
want more things after that but on a
delayed schedule
and um
sorry just just uh you know i'm out of
my own curiosity so
uh so there's this whole process and
then
what you know is there is there some
some vague idea about when this
deployment would actually happen or
what's is there a target or
what's a plausible
plausible timeline moving forward
so i mean a lot of that i suppose you
know comes down to the decisions of you
know organizations that are i guess
customers of standards right so you know
some point we'll write a standard and
it'll be published and it'll be you know
um
formal and approved and so on and then
um you know the hope is actually that
when we get these initial standards at
the end of the third round
in a couple of months and actually yeah
thank you noah for finding that on the
pqc forum
you know we've requested
new data implementations benchmarks
research paper script analysis
um so that we can
be aware of before we try and finalize
our internal evaluation and analysis we
suggested october 31st as a suitable day
to send that in or post it or whatever
you know make it open um but yeah in
terms of deployment the hope is that
once we you know pick some schemes
people start deploying
right away i mean you know
no time like the present
so
great um
thanks
um
dustin moody's chimed in in chat and
said we expect to have a final pkc
standard finalized by 2023
to 2024 so there'll be a decision and
then the drafting of the standards
document is
very involved
[Music]
great
well uh
let's see so unless there are there are
other questions maybe
maybe uh we can wrap up so thanks um
thanks to sean for a great talk and then
to the panel uh you know thanks for the
great discussion and also of course to
the
informal panelists chris and zika and
others and audience
that was
that was
very very enlightening
so um
so
i guess we'll see you next week for the
next
[Music]
you